what is going on everybody welcome to a
data analysis with Python in the pandas
module tutorial series in this series
we're going to be trying to cover pretty
much everything you might need to use
with the pandas module along with Python
for all kinds of different types of data
analysis so first of all python is the
programming language if you don't have
python already what you'll want to do is
head to python org and go to downloads
and download the latest version
basically this is for Windows because
I'm on Windows and they know that and so
just download the latest version don't
go with 2 7 or any version of 2 but if
say there's 3.6 or whatever or even
python 4 or something you should be able
to just download that now moving this
aside once you have python the way that
we are going to develop is i develop in
the basic IDL e but you can develop in
any ide that you want so if you're
following along and you use in a condo
with the spider ide or maybe you're
using ipython notebooks or pycharm
whatever it doesn't matter
fall along with whatever you want if
you're in an interactive development
environment just you probably don't have
to do print when we say you know the
data frame head or something like that
that doesn't mean much to you don't
worry about it next we're going to need
pandas this is the pandas website you
could download it from here and install
it from here but we're not going to do
that we're gonna use pip and then
finally this is my website python
programming that met all the tutorials
including this one are posted up here in
text form sample code is there
everything you can heed you'll be able
to find it here also if we cover a topic
that you don't really know about say we
cover Python dictionaries you can always
go to search and start typing Indic and
there we go and there are some
dictionaries for you so you could view
the basics tutorial on Python
dictionaries now that's that moving this
aside what we're going to do once you
have Python installed the next thing you
want to do is install pandas now pandas
has a bunch of requirements and stuff
like this and dependencies but we can
get pandas really quickly by doing a
simple pip install and us now if you run
pip install pandas and that doesn't work
for you it says many pip is not a
recognized
and then what you want to do is give the
full path to tip the way that you would
do that is C colon slash and then Python
your version number on three point four
so I would say 34 and this is scripts
and pip and then we would do install and
O's
now that should install pandas along
with numpy matplotlib if it doesn't or
at least to check just hit the up arrow
or whatever
now instead of pandas numpy and then
again so if numpy this time matplotlib
now as we go along especially at the
very end we'll talk about maybe SK learn
something like that and we'll need to
install that as well but nowadays you
know there's a million ways you can
install packages with Python nowadays
pip is got to be the easiest way to do
it so that's what we're going to use if
you don't if that doesn't work for you
I'll put a link in the description for
my pip install tutorial you can always
get pandas another way but I'm not going
to waste time on here everybody most
people should be fine with pip install
pandas now once you have that we go open
up here and then you're ready to put in
your data now the question that you
might have is what is pandas why would
we use this pandas module as opposed to
just writing python code because you
could take so so like pandas it
generally works with data frames you can
work with series to a series is like a
list with a column header and an index
but you could take like a data frame is
generally it's a lot like a spreadsheet
right if you print out that data frame
to the console you'll see that it looks
identical to a spreadsheet with column
headers it's got maybe an index with
maybe you've got dates there or a line
number or something like that and then
in between you've got all your data okay
and so it's a lot like maybe an Excel
spreadsheet if you're familiar now why
would we use Python over Excel well the
reason why I would use Python over excel
is Excel despite the name is not very
fast at all and it doesn't speed up for
you in fact as you get bigger it's going
to slow down and not be the greatest now
with Python things are going to be much
faster so I see a lot of people with
Excel starting to do machine learning
with like maybe k-means or something
like this
or can yours neighbors or whatever and
uh it's very slow I mean the whole
process even on a very relatively small
data set might take you three minutes or
something like that or even on a you
know medium sized data set most people
would call it large but on really a
medium size let's say you're dealing
with a couple gigabytes of data well
first of all if you're doing dealing
with more than like two gigabytes Excel
is gonna probably stop responding but
also it's going to be really slow it's
going to take it like 30 minutes to run
even even let's say you're not even
doing machine learning you're just
trying to do some basic calculations you
probably have a problem now you can tie
in Python to excel stuff like that and
there's other things other languages
that will tie in and help you speed it
up but eventually running headless with
something like Python or even C or
whatever is in your favor so then why
use Python over let's say C++ Python is
very friendly it's a lot of people kind
of nag on Python saying it's slow
especially slow compared to say C++
that's simply technically true but in
practice absolutely false okay
Python is almost as fast I mean we're
talking 99.9% is fast as C because
Python is written with C okay and a lot
of these packages like pandas and pandas
utilizes numpy that's a C library it's
just a Python wrapper around C okay so
because of that it's going to calculate
as fast to see because it is C okay so
so pandas with python and python with
numpy and all of these other packages
that people use for data analysis it's
just as fast and you get the loveliness
that python brings a table which is you
know really nice it's obviously static
types but so you've got you know the
syntax is just easy even for a newcomer
to understand it usually you can read it
and it makes sense so then finally why
would we use pandas rather than Python
plus say numpy well the reason why you
would use pandas is pandas is extremely
efficient it's basically built to make
your life easier so let me go ahead and
just show you a quick example I'm just
going to copy and paste this code
everything
that you're gonna see here we'll cover
in the series I'm just going to copy and
paste the code if you want to copy and
paste the code head to Python
programming net the data analysis or
dashboard then the data analysis tab you
can copy and paste the code as well if
you want to but really don't worry about
it as long as you're thinking you're
going to go - thanks video because we're
going to cover the code anyway I'm going
to copy paste here's some code we're
importing pandas as PD here it's just
standard to import it as pd's just a
shorthand way matplotlib for data
visualization if you want to know more
about matplotlib and data visualization
I actually have a pretty large tutorial
series for matplotlib found here I'll
put a link to that in the description
and it as we cover matplotlib will
probably mention that again but we're
not really going to focus too heavily on
data visualization this is data analysis
and manipulation now data visualization
is a form of data analysis sure but I
already have a very extensive series on
doing that with matplotlib so we're not
going to touch on that much so style is
just with matplotlib then we've got a
start and end date and we're using the
i/o of pandas this is another reason why
you would use pandas pandas is it works
with all kinds of data types and it can
work it can interact between data types
too so you can import from CSV output to
SQL or import from SQL output to HTML
import from HTML output to CSV and so on
you can kind of go between those
different data types and the most
beautiful thing is no matter what the
data type you import from is handling
the data frame is identical no matter
what so it's our way of kind of
normalizing all data sets or data types
rather anyway so start and then we use
this i/o data it's just a way of working
with a Web API basically so we're
referencing the Yahoo Finance API those
of you who are familiar with my
tutorials we usually end up doing
something with stock prices not going to
do stock prices still doing prices
though or at least markets we're going
to do the housing market with real
estate we'll just do some data analysis
on real estate information this is how
we can visualize the data frame we'll
talk more about that in the next
tutorial we can plot various columns
like adjusted it closes a column
we can show it so we'll go ahead save
and run that it's f5 for anyone who's
not familiar runs that here's the actual
pricing data dates at the bottom and
then here is just ahead of the data this
is the head is basically the top five
rows so there's obviously a lot more
data points here's just these are the
first five so then you've got date open
high/low close date is lower than all
these other columns because date is
being treated as an index which we'll
talk about in the next tutorial but
that's basically it so as you can kind
of see now especially visually pandas is
going to put things into what you would
probably call a spreadsheet like format
same thing with like maybe a table in a
database same same sort of thing I mean
this is kind of this is how people are
accustomed to handling data so it's it
works with you that way and you
shouldn't be too uncomfortable working
with the data frame it should be
relatively a normal feeling to you but
as we go on being able to apply various
calculations analysis statistical kind
of stuff on even massive data sets is
very fast and very efficient so it's
definitely very useful and there's a lot
of pre-built
commands in there for you so you don't
have to really worry about writing them
and pandas at the end of the day is
highly customizable there's ways you can
map functions either to the entire data
frame make a new column based on a new
function or even make rolling applies
and stuff like that so anyways lot stuff
for us to cover if you have questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them in the comments below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support of
subscriptions and it till next time